[Music]
this map shows the maximum range of
China's land-based conventional strike
missiles in 2015 less than a decade
later that range has doubled putting all
American bases in the Asia Pacific
including Guam within the range of
precision missiles fired from the
Chinese Mainland a secretive Chinese
military unit is responsible for that
expansion and Now controls one of the
largest and most diverse land-based
missile forces in the world details of
the force are some of China's most LLY
guarded
Secrets but Western intelligence
agencies and researchers have revealed
evidence of its dramatic rise China has
rapidly increased its missile Arsenal
this is a menacing challenge to the
United
States in August 2023 Chinese leader Xi
Jinping suddenly ousted and replaced the
head of an opaque military unit called
the Rocket Force China's leaders have
tasked this force with its highest
military
objective preparing for a possible
invasion of
Taiwan and deterring the United States
from
intervening in recent years the force
has test launched hundreds of ballistic
missiles at a rate that has exceeded the
rest of the world combined Alexander
Neil is a former Defense analyst for the
British government the pla rocket Force
has six bases spread across China in an
arc in the South which are responsible
for a potential Taiwan conflict then up
in the Northeast which is responsible
for Korean Peninsula and targeting Japan
there's a dedicated base in central
China and finally a base which is
responsible for the northwest of China
on top of these six main bases which are
numbered from 61 to 66 the rocket Force
also has several supporting bases one of
which is regarded as the most
important base 67 is the most
secretive of the pla rocket Force basis
the guardian of China's strategic
nuclear
deterrent little is known about the base
in bgi city in central China but bunker
dug into the Chingling mountain range on
the outskirts of the city houses most of
China's nuclear warhead stock pile from
base 67 the WarHeads are subsequently
distributed by rail all across China
Northwest Northeast and and into the
South across the brigades responsible
for launch and deployments of the
nuclear
deterrent the bases in China's North are
tasked with maintaining nuclear capable
intercontinental ballistic missiles
focused on Targets on the US Mainland a
number of scientists looking at civilian
imagery spotted three new missile silo
Fields under
development the The Silo fields are
based in very desertified areas outside
of Hami Yen City and ordor City silos
are built as circular tubes into the
ground and contain propellants to launch
missiles you can see here The ordos Silo
field which is typically made up of
about a 100 silos here an important
aspect of Silo Fields is something
called a shell game you might have 100
silos but you may fill only 50% of them
and the adversary has to calculate which
of those silos are armed in order to
make a calculation for a Counter Strike
and a shell game is designed to keep the
adversary guessing and also to reserve
your own number of warheads as well the
construction in odos kamami and yum is
thought to be the most extensive buildup
of missile silos since the Cold War if
China mounts nuclear warheads on
missiles in these silos it would present
a huge strategic shift for US military
planners you can see here that the Arc
of the three Silo Fields is designed to
launch missiles over the North
Pole and to the continental United
States all this could give Beijing the
military capability to deter Washington
from engaging China militarily in the
event of an invasion of
Taiwan the rocket Force recently
demonstrated its capability to strike
Taiwan during a conflict subordinate to
base 61 are a number of brigades
involved in the targeting of Taiwan
during missile tests when Nancy Pelosi
visited Taiwan in August
2022 China conducted several days of
military exercises a number of short and
intermediate range missiles were
launched into exclusion Zone
to the north and south of Taiwan one of
them was to the East and Seaboard and
there were also some short range rocket
firings between Taiwan and fuan
Province China has been building up its
missile capacity near Taiwan for years
but drills during Pelosi's visit
demonstrate the rocket Force's new
capability to Target the entire
periphery of Taiwan these brigades are
one of the sharpest Tools in their
Arsenal to mount a devast ating missile
attack on the island to blockade the
island to close off shipping lanes and
to mount a strangle hold on the island
during times of political
sensitivity China used taiwan's autonomy
and its links with the us as a
geostrategic vulnerability so if we flip
the map it depicts the challenge that
China is facing it's it's hemmed in to
some degree by the first island chain
and and to a lesser extent by the second
island chain it's a a dilemma of oceanic
geography but in a military sense this
is why the rocket force is so important
the rocket force would play a key role
to prevent intervention of the United
States and allies were War to breakout
over
Taiwan the rocket Force developed
missiles capable of striking US forces
coming to taiwan's Aid within the first
and second Island chains one of these is
the dong Fang 26 known as the carrier
killer the weapon has been deployed to a
number of brigades posing a challenge to
the US the df-26 can be either
conventionally armed or nuclear armed it
can accurately Target bases like Guam
but it can also Target an aircraft
carrier strike group so this presents a
major challenge for United States in
terms of its counter intervention
campaign the Biden ad Administration has
said US forces will support Taiwan in
the event of a Chinese
Invasion China's rocket Force now
presents a serious threat to the US's
ability to do that dramatically raising
the stakes in any conflict over the
island China's Ministry of defense did
not respond to a request for
comment